Hallo, hallo, hallo, wer ist da?
Noch keiner, nicht mal der, der, der Feuja am, am Abo-Box-Campen.
Vielleicht sind die Leute auch durch den Titel abgeschränkt.
Es hat nichts mit dem zu tun, was ihr euch vielleicht denken mögt.
Hört der mich überhaupt?
Hört der mich? Ja, ja, okay. Man weiß ja nie.
Ah, doch jetzt, jetzt hat's Twitch. Erster Hog.
Jetzt hat's Twitch mitgekriegt.
Hat gedauert.
Schon gedacht, Twitch, Twitch steckt's nicht.
Oder wohl davon kackt ab, oder? Als allererstes habe ich ehrlich gesagt gedacht, mein Mikrofon ist nicht richtig dran.
Oh, ich muss mein Mikrofon umstecken. Ich bin zu faul, mein Mikrofon umzustecken, das...
Aber es klingt besser, wenn ich's umstecke.
Aber keinen Bock, mein Mikrofon umzustecken.
Kack, wait. Okay, Chat, weil ihr es seid, ich stöpsel mein Mikrofon um.
So, jetzt hört sich besser an, ne?
Take Viagra, die hard. IQ-Boost, ja, so muss das sein. Extremly Pog.
Max, was hältst du von Mojo? Da habe ich mich ja schon mal dazu ausgelassen in den letzten Streams. Wir haben das übrigens auf unserer
Stream-To-Do-Liste stehen,
dass wir uns das demnächst mal angucken. Ich habe auf Stream ganz kurz mit den offiziellen Guides schon mal durchgelesen und
ein paar Sachen waren mir da nicht so klar. Das ist aber schon eine Woche her, ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern. Zumindest
ich finde es von der Idee her nicht schlecht, aber ich verstehe nicht und was ich auch ein bisschen bedenklich gar schon finde ist, dass es
kein Open Source ist. Verstehe ich nicht. In Zeiten, wo so ziemlich alle, sogar Java, also naja,
ja doch, sogar Java
und die Frameworks, Runtimes und Implementierungen alle Open Source sind, verstehe ich nicht, warum das
Closed Source ist.
Morphos hat ein Video zu mir, es haben viele ein Video dazu gemacht. Ich meine, die Idee, dass man endlich, also
es ist ja nicht der einzige Python-Compiler, gibt es ja noch mehrere, wobei das ja nicht wirklich ein Compiler ist, sondern
es ist ein Compiler plus eine Spracherweiterung im Endeffekt.
Wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin, bei Mojo ist, wie es aussieht mit
Python-C-Extensions und sowas, ob das alles gescheit funktioniert. Ich würde mal darauf tippen, ja, aber weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, habe ich ausprobiert. Ansonsten finde ich es eine gute Sache,
was sicherlich den ganzen Python-Bros gefallen wird,
die irgendwie der Meinung sind, es ist die einzige Sprache, die es gibt.
Aber gut, sie hätten sich auch was Schlechteres zum Einstieg aussuchen können.
Der Titel ist übrigens ernst gemeint vom Stream. Mir tut sowas von meinen Arsch weh.
Und wisst ihr auch warum? Es hat, es hat nichts mit HyperGadget zu tun und es hat auch nichts mit C++ zu tun. Ich meine,
C++ bereitet Schmerzen, aber von C++ tut einem noch nicht der Hintern weh.
Wobei man nicht sicher sein kann, bei C++.
Also bei C++ könnte auch Hinterschmerzen verursachen.
Bist du Fahrrad gefahren? Richtig.
Ich, Finanzamt entschuldigt. Ja, da fühlt man sich manchmal so, aber nein, ich bin Fahrrad gefahren gestern
25 Kilometer
und heute 32 Kilometer.
Ich meine, für den einen oder anderen mag es nicht lang sein. Für mich, also ich muss, ich muss sagen,
es ist nicht so, dass ich irgendwie voll fertig wäre oder so danach.
Max, wie kommt es, dass du auf Twitch anders heißt, weil ich Wobloss bin?
Also der Grund ist, ich glaube wir haben sogar ein Kommando dafür, der Grund ist,
dass ich den Channel schon erstellt habe, bevor ich selbst streamen wollte
und dann habe ich den einfach weiter genommen und fand es gar nicht so schlecht, weil es auf YouTube
auch viele nervige Leute gibt und wenn die Leute, das selektiert schon mal so ein bisschen vor, ja, wer den Weg hierhin findet, kann nicht so total bescheuert sein.
Hsjui, dankeschön für den Sub. Naja, was, was, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ja, habe ich, habe ich. Ich habe so eine, so eine Hose,
so eine Hose mit einem Polster drin. Wie heißt das hier, Amazon?
Äh, Bib?
Sowas hier in der Regel. Natürlich,
ich sehe exakt so aus, wenn ich die anhabe. 1 zu 1.
Gut, dass, gut, gut, dass, dass die ein Bild da drin haben.
Ja, aber so ein Teil, so ein Teil habe ich auch. Da ist ein, da ist ein, da ist ein, das ist natürlich bescheuert, das Wichtigste sieht man gar nicht.
Da ist ein Polster drin.
Wie die das Wichtigste nicht zeigen, Alter.
Da ist ein Polster im Poppes,
da ist ein Polster im Poppes,
was man irgendwie aus irgendwelchen, ah, hier sieht man es glaube ich.
Ja, hier, da.
Da ist ein Polster im Poppes.
Also an der, an der Hose.
Das ist tatsächlich praktisch.
Leute, Leute, wenn ich ohne Polster fahren würde,
dann würde mir noch mehr der Hintern wehtun.
Bei Radhosen übereinander.
Ja.
Und,
wie gesagt, ich bin, also,
bei meinen Ausfahrten, ich bin ja ewig
unterwegs,
bei meinen Ausfahrten,
ich bin ja ewig nicht Fahrrad gefahren, ne,
also bei meinen Ausfahrten,
ich habe kreislaufmäßig überhaupt
nicht das Problem.
Im Gegensatz zum Rennen.
Beim Rennen bin ich da, da muss ich es ja immer
übertreiben,
hab dann irgendwas zwischen,
naja, sagen wir mal so, wenn ich mich zusammenreiße,
145, 150
Puls und wenn ich normal renne,
so 155
oder so,
beim Fahrradfahren hab ich keine Ahnung,
irgendwie 100, 115
bis 135 oder so,
je nachdem, wo man ein bisschen strampeln
muss, aber ich hab beim Fahrradfahren
andere Probleme. Das erste ist,
mir tut der Arsch weh,
nach
10 Kilometern oder so,
mir tut der Arsch weh und, aber
ich geh davon aus, dass sich
das mit der Zeit noch ein bisschen legen wird.
Mir tut der Arsch weh und,
was ich heute auch gemerkt hab,
ich muss wahrscheinlich mal ein bisschen am Sattel reinstellen,
rumstellen oder mal
irgendein Bike-Fitting
Termin
machen,
ich hab heute zu sehr
auf den,
ich hab heute
zu sehr
auf den Händen gehangen,
sodass ich jetzt
sowohl links als auch rechts,
die Spitze von meinem
Zeigefinger fühlt sich ein bisschen,
das ist das falsche Wort,
komisch an.
Das liegt dadurch, dass ich halt
übelst auf die Hand gedrückt hab und da
gehen halt Nerven durch. Das sagt halt auch.
So, das ist das zweite
und
was
hab ich denn ansonsten noch?
Das war's
eigentlich. Sonst
tut mir nix weh.
Und wie gesagt, also am nervigsten
ist das tatsächlich, dass mir der Hintern weh tut.
Aber es ging.
Ja, naja.
Also ich hatte ganz kurz,
ich hatte ganz kurz mal
Puls oder sowas, als
ich die Brücke raufgefahren bin.
Volle Pulle.
Ja, siehste?
Ja.
Ich denke auch, dass sich das
legt, dass man
Schmerzen im Porpoise hat.
Aber ich muss das insgesamt
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen gescheiter
einstellen, das Fahrrad, ja.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich aber den Sattel ein bisschen hinter machen,
dass ich nicht so volle Pulle
auf den Ärmen häng.
Du hast doch so einen Teil
für deinen Server,
mit dem du den steuern kannst. Wie heißt das Teil nochmal?
SSH?
Ups, bisschen groß. Leicht zu groß
ist E-Mode. SSH?
Oder, hä? Das wirst du aber nicht meinen, oder?
Ach, ich weiß,
du meinst den KVM-Switch.
Du meinst den KVM-Switch.
Ähm, das
ist ein
wie heißt die?
Lantronics oder so?
Spider.
Ich mach mal den Streamtitel
etwas weniger gachi-bass-lastig.
Wobei,
lass das einfach so.
Du meinst das Ding hier,
gell?
Aufkaufen und stellen, also auf, her damit.
Ja. Das, so ein Teil
hab ich. Mit dem Unterschied,
dass ich das damals für 75 Euro
oder irgendwas gekauft hab.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum der Scheiß so krass teuer ist.
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Man bekommt ein VGA-Port
und zwei USB-Anschlüsse.
Gut, mein, der Vorteil ist halt
davon,
jede 0815-Server hat halt
noch so ein VGA-Port.
Und hier kannst du halt
per Netzwerk
aufconnecten und
der Technik-Kreisel ist am Start.
Kreisel-Kreisel.
Aber das
eigentlich coole ist da dran,
das ist ein Produkt, wir haben das ja mal zusammen
benutzt im Stream.
Das ist ein Produkt von 2009
oder sowas.
Das ist richtig alt.
Und die haben letztens ein Firmware-Update
gebracht für das Ding,
dass es jetzt ein HTML5
JavaScript-Interface hat,
ohne Java,
Applets und Flash und Geschiss.
Vor zwei Jahren oder so haben die das rausgebracht.
Für ein
15 Jahre altes Gerät.
Da kann man sich nicht
beschweren, oder?
Okay.
Also das Ding meinst du, ne?
Ganz ehrlich, für den Preis würde ich mir das
nicht kaufen. Wir können ja mal kurz schauen.
Wir können ja mal kurz schauen,
ob es das irgendwo ein bisschen billiger gibt.
Es gibt irgendwas ohne Gehäuse oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Also ich hatte richtig Glück anscheinend.
Wie gesagt, ich hab das damals für, ich weiß nicht genau
wie viel, 75,
95 irgendwie.
Ich hab das super
günstig im Vergleich zu den jetzigen Preisen
gekauft.
Vielleicht, das könnte sein,
dass die,
dass damals viele ausgemustert
wurden, dass es einfach extrem viel auf Ebay gab
oder so. Hängt das Stream?
Nö, der Stream hängt nicht. Ich sehe es in meinem
Vorschau. Hier hängt nichts,
null, gar nichts hängt hier im Stream.
Überhaupt nichts.
Ebay Kleinanzeigen.
Achso,
das ist ja nicht mehr Ebay.
Das ist ja nicht mehr Ebay.
Da gibt es doch gar nichts hier.
Ah doch, hier.
300? Aber das ist
aber auch ein neuerer.
Print Server brauchen
sowas.
Äh...
NTP Zeitserver?
Was zum...
Achso.
Ah, das ist sowas mit GPS-Modul und sowas.
Also, naja, gut.
So, also wenn man
wirklich, wenn man wirklich ein GPS
haben möchte für eigenen Zeitserver,
dann kann man das tatsächlich super easy
mit nem ESP32
mit nem GPS-Modul machen.
Da gibt es schon Fixer und Fixer und Fertiger, guck.
Also wenn man, ich finde es bescheuert.
Braucht niemand, aber man kann
ESP32
mit GPS...
Äh, nee, nicht...
GPS... Guck, da gibt es
da gibt es fertige Boards, da ist
da ist sogar noch mehr drauf, da ist
ähm...
Guck mal, da ist sogar noch LoRa drauf
und alles mögliche. Kann man sich so ein Board kaufen für...
Die sind aber auch ganz schön teuer geworden, Alter.
Die gibt's bei AliExpress
für 15 Euro. Alter, was ist...
Haha, was ist mit euch los, Alter?
Das kostet bei Ali... Okay, passt mal auf mal.
Das muss ich mal... AliExpress.
AliExpress, das muss ich mal kurz vergleichen.
Was ist mit den Amazon-Preisen los?
Sind die komplett wahnsinnig, oder was?
Ei, die China-Chinesen
kriegen nix.
AliExpress.
AliExpress, China-Chinesen-Seite.
Auf, mach hinne.
Nicht genug AWS-Ressorts.
Nee, nee, nicht AWS. Die benutzen ja nicht AWS.
Die haben ja ne eigene Cloud.
Da ist in China gerade Hochwasser
oder Erdbeben oder irgendwas.
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht, vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Manchmal kann man die Chibaden, wenn man
Inkognito-Modus anmacht.
Was?
AliExpress.
Ihr seid highly pepega.
Siehste, ich sag doch Inkognito-Modus.
Hier. TTGO-T-Strahl.
Weil das Ding T-Beam heißt.
7,66 Euro.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ist... Ah, Moment.
Das ist mit dem alten LoRa-Modul.
Aber jemand, der nur für GPS interessiert,
ist das ja okay.
Also wie gesagt, die gibt es relativ
relativ günstig bei den China-Chinesen.
Da kann man sich das
mit GPS holen. Dann hat man die Zeit davon.
7LQRS.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription. Hier.
LinkedIn einloggen.
Ich hab meinen Account hier nicht.
Beziehungsweise
ich hab ja das Login zu meinem Account
allgemein. Kann man da vielleicht
Inkognito starten? Ach, Inkognito
starten geht.
Alter. Die Seiten sind so fail
alle. Okay.
Für welches Fahrrad kann ich
gleich noch was dazu sagen.
Kann ich gleich noch dazu sagen.
Die Zeit für die 5 Kilometer ist ja
mega brutal, in welchem kurzen Zeitraum
das so vorwärtsgegangen ist.
Du meinst 5 Minuten 45
für pro Kilometer?
Das letzte was ich gepostet hab
da war ich echt
im Arsch danach.
Moment, wir haben ein Kommando für mein Fahrrad?
Hahaha.
Leute.
Leute, da müssen wir
da müssen wir jetzt einmal kurz
für die Mods.
Ihr müsst jetzt einmal alle
im Chat Mod
check. Ich mach mit.
Mod check.
Um mal unseren Mods zu huldigen.
Dass die immer so auf Zack sind.
Ja, siehste.
Sehr schön.
Es gehört ja auch zu einem guten Mod-Gild dabei,
dass der das so antizipiert.
Was da so als Questions immer rumkommen.
Massive
Five Head Mods.
Okay, dann schieben wir das mal kurz vor der Schnellen Anzeige ein.
Korrekt, das ist
mein Fahrrad.
Ja.
Richtig. So sieht das aus.
Genau so schaut das aus.
Also ich farbe nicht ganz, aber
das sieht auf jeden Fall
anders aus wie auf dem Bild.
Aber
das ist das Fahrrad,
was ich mir gekauft hab. Und ich hatte
ja am Anfang
weiß nicht, ob die hier ein Bild davon haben.
Äh, die haben nur ein Bild von der
anderen Seite. Das ist natürlich doof.
Ja.
Ich hatte am Anfang ja ein bisschen Bedenken.
Weil du hast
hier nur vorne
ein Ring, also ein Kettenblatt.
Und hinten hast du halt 11-42
Ritzel,
sagt da der Fachmann.
Zumindest
hab ich halt gedacht,
ob das nicht ein bisschen wenig ist mit nur
einem Blatt vorne und kommt man da
ordentlich hoch. Man kommt ohne
Probleme ordentlich den Berg hoch, Leute.
Das einzige
Problem, was ich habe, ist
nicht so sehr die Übersetzung, sondern
der Oberschenkel, der noch nicht so richtig mitmacht.
Neben
all den anderen Sachen, die ich euch erzählt hab.
Ja.
Also, übersetzungsmäßig ist es gar kein
Problem. Also die Berge,
die ich hochgefahren bin bisher,
ich bin ja nicht wirklich viele Berge, also viele
Steigungen gefahren, Berge schon noch gar nicht,
war sowas wie
mal irgendwie
die Autobahnbrücke hoch,
so am Fußgängeraufstieg da
und so. Das war dann schon mal
irgendwie so
13, 14 Prozent oder sowas,
aber das konnte ich ohne
Probleme durchstrampeln.
Im kleinsten Gang war die
Übersetzung fast ein bisschen zu
leicht. Da hab ich,
musste ich dann irgendwie ultraschnell treten,
dass das Fahrrad nicht umkippt, so lahm war das sonst.
Aber
meine Oberschenkel machen es noch nicht so ganz mit.
Ja.
Also so sieht mein Fahrrad aus.
Und das stimmt übrigens nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was die,
das wiegt 9 Kilo, ich hab keine Ahnung, was die da
gewogen haben. Das wiegt
ein bisschen mehr als 9 Kilo.
Keine Ahnung, was da mit den,
da ist ein Sternchen dahinter.
Was bedeutet denn das Sternchen?
Ah, ich hab die falsche,
ich hab die falsche Rahmenfarbe.
Ich hab's auch ohne Pedale.
Mein Fahrrad ist ein Ticken
kleiner.
Mein Fahrrad ist ein Ticken kleiner
und ohne Pedale hab ich das gemessen.
Heißt im Endeffekt,
naja, was auch immer.
Es ist trotzdem mega leicht.
Richtig, es macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied.
Ähm, das,
da bin ich dann auch drauf gekommen. Es macht eigentlich gar keinen
Unterschied, wie rechtfertigen
die den Preis. Also es macht eigentlich,
es macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied,
so richtig, weil du hast
trotzdem 40 zu
42. Das, ich mein,
du hättest, du hättest bei dem anderen, hättest du dann
glaub,
34 zu
oder so gehabt. Das heißt,
bisschen weniger vielleicht, aber macht keinen
Unterschied. Ja das stimmt, dir fehlt der aller,
dir fehlt halt
die ganz, die ganz, ähm,
großen Gänge. Aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich, wenn ich mal 30
kmh fahre, dann kann ich das eh nicht lange.
Nein,
nein, hab ich nicht. Ich hab noch keine
Klickschuhe. Will ich auch
erstmal nicht, weil ich noch ganz schön am rumwackeln
bin oftmals. Das mach ich,
das mach ich erst, wenn ich das andere
im Schlaf kann.
Ich hab mir da so Pedale mitbestellt,
die man auf der einen Seite reinklicken
kann, auf der anderen Seite
ähm, sich mit dem Fuß draufstellen
kann. Die, also, die wurden
direkt im Checkout
Prozess empfohlen. Aber so geil
find ich das nicht, weil du dann immer erstmal suchen musst
die Seite, wo du halt mit nem normalen
Schuh drauf kommst. Das heißt, ich werd vielleicht
erstmal ganz normale Pedale dran machen,
die auf beiden Seiten flach sind.
Ja. Also, wie der Preis
gerechtfertigt ist, ist das eigentlich relativ
einfach zu erklären.
Das ist ein,
die erklären's hier, das ist ein kompletter
Carbon-Rahmen.
Das sind tubeless Reifen,
das sind
Carbon-Gabel,
Carbon-Lenker,
Scheiben,
Dingsbums, Bremsen,
elektronische
Schaltung.
Also, ich hab mir im Vorfeld ein bisschen schlau
gemacht.
Das ist preis-leistungsmäßig echt nicht
verkehrt. Ansonsten kann ich
es nicht wirklich einschätzen.
Ja. Aber für irgendwas
muss ich ja mal meine Kohle ausgeben.
Macht mega Bock damit zu fahren,
das Einzige ist halt, mein Arsch tut weh, weil
ich's nicht gewöhnt bin. Ja.
Das ist Pech, ja.
Schloss hab ich auch eins.
So ein ganz kleines, billiges,
leichtes, was man
einstecken kann. Was reicht,
wenn man mal kurz zum Bäcker geht, aber aus den Augen
würde ich's damit nicht lassen.
Zwölf Kilo. Was sperrst
du damit immer so an?
So safe to go, oder?
Schauen wir uns im Stream den Raspberry
Pi zusammen an. Ja. Aber
erst morgen früh wahrscheinlich, nicht heute Abend.
Ich hab schon
ein Video auf.
Schon spät, ja. Boomer müde.
Gut.
Also, ich wollte
doch irgendwas machen.
Ach ja, die Stellenanzeige.
Wo hab ich denn die hin?
Ja.
Nein.
Oh. Moment.
Moment, Leute. Erweiterung verwalten.
Darkreader. Oh,
nee. Ich hab keinen Darkreader hier.
MonkaW.
Dann
müssen wir mal kurz...
Oh, Moment.
Extensions und Darkreader
ist doch an.
Darkreader, Details, kann man nicht sagen.
Allow incognito.
So.
Darkreader.
Okay. Nice. Jetzt haben wir's.
Es werden keine Bewerbungen mehr angenommen.
Oh, nein. Okay. Also,
das soll ich mir angucken. Dann lasst uns das doch mal anschauen.
Chat, wer hat die
Stellenanzeige gepostet und ist das
jetzt auch die richtige, die dabei rausgekommen ist,
als ich den Inkognito-Modus aufgemacht hab?
Ist das die, die ich
gucken soll? Ist die richtige?
Okay. Auf geht's.
Also. Wen haben wir denn also?
Die HDI-Crew. Von denen hab ich nie was
gehört. Keine Ahnung.
Gehören sie zu den ersten 25 Bewerbern?
Es werden keine Bewerbungen mehr angenommen.
Nice.
Hast du jetzt was zum Standort-Tracken
im Fahrrad drin?
Das sag ich nicht.
Nee. Hab ich nicht.
Ich hab aktuell einfach mein Handy dabei.
Und ich bin noch am überlegen,
wie ich das mache, weil
ich hab ja da mein Navi
drauf.
Das ist kein Navi, das ist ein Fahrradcomputer vorne drauf.
Und der kann theoretisch tracken,
aber weiß nicht, wie gut das funktioniert.
Vielleicht werd ich da irgendwas verstecken
irgendwo im Rahmen drin oder so,
dass man das tracken kann.
Muss ich mal schauen. Ich hoffe ja eher drauf,
dass es erst gar nicht geklaut wird.
Nun gut. Also.
And Operations Engineer.
Nee, AirTag ist doof.
Also, ihre
Aufgaben. Verantwortung für kontinuierlichen
und stabilen Anwendungsbetrieb
sowie die Fehleranalyse
Ups.
Fehleranalyse und Behebung.
Ja gut.
Als Cloud und Operations
Engineer, würd ich sagen,
klingt das ja mal ganz gut passend.
Bereitstellung, also diese Stellenanzeigen
Es gibt ja keine
Norm für Berufsbezeichnungen
in der IT.
So ein paar Sachen haben sich rauskristallisiert,
aber viele nennen die Sachen halt so,
wie sie gerade Bock haben.
Aber ich find, das passt zumindest jetzt
schon mal ganz gut zusammen.
Bereitstellung von Infrastrukturen auf
eigenen cloudbasierten Umgebungen.
Ja, als Cloud
Operations Engineer.
Entwicklung.
Standardisierung und Betreuung von
Containerlösungen in Kubernetes.
Ja gut. Und passt,
denke ich, auch ganz gut dabei.
Aktives Lifecycle Management von
eigenen und Third-Party
Anwendungen.
Ich tu mir mit dem Wort
Lifecycle Management immer schwer, Leute.
Ich hab da schon so ne grobe Idee.
Immer, was im
jeweiligen Kontext mit gemeint ist.
Aber für mich ist dieses Wort Lifecycle
Management immer unglaublich schwer zu greifen.
Chat, wer von euch
es gibt jetzt ein Sub zu
gewinnen. Wer von euch
schafft es mir in maximal drei
Sätzen Lifecycle Management
so zu erklären,
dass ich's checke,
der Erste gewinnt.
Und wenn das keiner
hinkriegt, dann bin ich
auch froh, weil
mit oder ohne
Chat-GPT, wie du willst.
Problem ist, bei Chat-GPT
kommt halt oftmals Mist raus.
Das hast du im Leben
nicht jetzt runtergeschrieben.
Einfach so.
Das war...
Das ist das Offensichtlichste.
Okay, Leute. Ich schließe da raus.
Jetzt lasst...
Chat, Chat.
Ich schließe da raus. Ihr habt auch keine Ahnung.
Beziehungsweise ist es auch enorm
schwierig für euch zu erklären.
Leute,
Chat-GPT
pasten.
Ne, dafür gibt's
jetzt kein Sub.
Gut, also gucken wir mal weiter.
Monitoring und
Dokumentation für Standardanwendungen
und Infrastrukturen.
Dokumentation braucht man nicht, wenn alles
immer perfekt first try funktioniert.
Monitoring und Dokumentation
für Standardanwendungen und Infrastrukturen.
Ja, finde ich Operations
Bisschen aufschreiben, was Sache ist.
Sachen überprüfen, ob sie noch laufen.
Beziehungsweise ob irgendwelche
Auffälligkeiten auftreten. Das finde ich
passt gut dazu. Umsetzung
von Anforderungen in einem agilen
Team. Okay, heute ist alles agile,
safe, lean und
try und... Wobei das eine
mit dem anderen nichts zu tun hat.
Try, solid
und
T-shaped
und... Was habe ich noch
vergessen? Kannbarn!
Natürlich, Kannbarn.
Erfolgreich abgeschlossenes Hochschul-
oder vergleichbare Ausbildung. Okay, der Standardsatz
schlechthin.
Erste Erfahrung mit Cloud-Technologien
und relevanten Tools.
Ehrlich gesagt, finde ich, passt das nicht so
hundertprozentig zusammen.
Ich meine, du sollst dich um die Entwicklung, Standardisierung
und Betreuung von Containerlösungen und Kubernetes
kümmern. Du bist... Okay, na doch. Ne, ne.
Passt schon, passt schon, passt schon. Das ist eine
Junior-Stelle. Habe ich jetzt gar nicht hingeguckt.
Okay, das heißt, die
setzen auch ein bisschen drauf, zumindest interpretiere
ich das da so rein,
dass man dort
anfängt und zwar das zu den Aufgaben gehört,
aber man da noch reinwächst. Ja, das finde ich
ja eigentlich nicht verkehrt.
Basiswissen über... Also
zumindest rate ich jetzt
das an der Stelle so.
Basiswissen über DevOps-Methoden,
CI-CD-Pipelines
und agile Arbeitsweise.
Agile Arbeitsweise definiert
eh jeder andere.
Jeder ein bisschen anders.
Eigeninitiative und in manchen Bereichen ist
agile Arbeitsweise auch komplett unsinnig.
Ja? Also zum Beispiel,
wenn du so ganz
klassische
Operating-Strukturen hast,
so einmal in der Woche
ein Change-Meeting,
zwei Wochen im Voraus eintragen
in die Excel-Tabelle und hast du nicht gesehen,
da ist da mit Agilität nicht
allzu viel hin. Und wer das
die Agile nennt, nur weil es cool klingt,
der untergräbt eigentlich
so den ganzen Sinnhaftigkeit
davon. Eigeninitiative
und Einsatzbereitschaft
sowie gute Problemlösungskompetenz.
Ja, das kann ich
tatsächlich nur unterschreiben. Ich meine,
Einsatzbereitschaft, immer
im Rahmen, kommt immer auch ein bisschen drauf an,
wie einem die andere Seite entgegenkommt, aber
Eigeninitiative zum Schritt halten
mit der Entwicklung, so ein bisschen musst du dich
so drumherum beschäftigen, von dir
aus, aus so Eigenantrieb.
Sonst
wird das auf Dauer nix. Kommunikationsstärke
und die Fähigkeit, Gespräche
ergebnisoffen zu führen, so wie gut deutsche
Kommunikationsstärke. Wir machen es
dann so wie der Patrick mit seiner Firma.
Entweder ihr kacknoobs, ihr kauft
jetzt einfach mein Zeug
oder leckt mich.
So, ich glaube, so muss man das machen.
Das... Oh!
Sad Girl.
Einer, warum sterben die alle?
Da mache ich mir langsam Gedanken.
Ich meine, ich bin 39.
Aber wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Kenntnisse über Prozesse der Versicherungswirtschaft
wünschenswert. Hey, da wäre ich
ja genau der richtige
Kandidat für.
Be you.
Bei uns steht der Mensch im
Fokus. Wir leben
eine Unternehmenskultur,
der Offenheit sowie Wertschätzung garantieren
allen Mitarbeitern und
Kandidaten Chancengleichheit.
So schaffen wir
ein Umfeld, in dem das persönliche
Potential bestmöglich entfaltet
werden kann.
Ah, ja.
Ich finde es
gar nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, es ist ein Juniorjob
und ich finde, das spiegelt sich auch
in dieser Aussage hier wieder.
Also ganz ehrlich, Jobtitel,
Aufgaben
und was sie so suchen,
finde ich,
passt recht gut dazu.
Es ist zwar immer noch recht
kurz, knackig,
trocken, wobei kurz und knackig
finde ich bei Stellenanzeigen immer gut.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt
nichts, wo ich in wahnsinnige Verzückung
geraten würde und sagen, oh, das muss ich mir...
Aber es klingt
nicht schlecht.
Ja, also es ist jetzt nicht
übertriebene Euphorie nach dem Lesen oder so,
aber
es klingt passend
von den Aufgaben, vom Profil her.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, ob die
jetzt auch noch gescheit bezahlen.
Ja, ich denke, da kann man
sich bewerben, Chatgy.
Ja. Guckst du sowas?
Ah, live?
Live
Underflow.
Er heißt doch...
Ist es ein
Zweitchannel?
Live Overflow, ja, wollte ich gerade
sagen.
Ja.
Das gucken wir in 37 Minuten.
Leute, wenn ich mir heute ein 37-Minuten-Video
angucke, dann sind wir
morgen noch nicht fertig.
Warum zum Teufel haben wir
PC-Welt auf?
Wait a minute, bin ich hier im...
Ich bin hier im
Musik-Chrome.
Da bin ich falsch.
Ich muss in den...
Ich muss in den
Facebook-Chrome.
Gibt das morgen vor...
Ja, morgen im Auffach-Stream gucken wir uns das an.
Und da gucken wir uns auch
das Video zum Raspberry Pi an.
Hast du Ideen, was
die so im Bewerbungsgespräch fragen können?
Kommt drauf an, wer
dabei ist.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wer
dabei ist, weil
der...
Der Personalmensch wird
natürlich was anderes fragen als sein zukünftiger
Teamleiter oder wer auch immer
alles dabei ist.
Ich denke, du wirst in der Position
sicherlich, zumindest im
Forschungsgespräch, kannst du sicherlich, wenn da
einer dabei ist, der ein bisschen Ahnung von der
Technik hat, mit den ein oder
anderen Cloud-Anbieter bezogenen
Sachen rechnen, zum Beispiel
Richtung
Kosten
von Cloud-Infrastruktur
zum Beispiel.
Okay,
wie würden sie das und das aufbauen?
So kosteneffizient,
da kannst du denen erzählen, so nach dem Motto,
man sollte nach Möglichkeit keine
Azure Functions oder so bauen,
die sich selbst gegenseitig im Kreis
aufrufen.
Alter, was ist mit der Musik los?
Haben wir nicht irgendwo Rainbow Road oder sowas?
Jawohl, Rainbow Road, beste.
Und ansonsten werden die dich
die üblichen Sachen fragen.
Oh, da bin ich jetzt der Falsche.
Ich bin froh, dass ich das durch hab.
Also, ich
wurde beispielsweise im Vorstellungsgespräch
gefragt, was sind Sachen, die sie so
richtig, oder nee, was müssten wir machen,
um sie so richtig aufzuregen? Das ist so eine typische
äh
Five-Head-Psychologie-Frage
von der Personalabteilung
und solche
Sachen.
Also, was du auf jeden Fall machen solltest, ist,
wenn du das ernst nimmst,
also, falls du da wirklich hin willst, also
gibt ja auch Leute, die suchen sich was raus, ein bisschen zum
Üben, aber wenn du es wirklich ernst nimmst
und da auch Absichten hast zu,
dann würde ich mir auf jeden Fall denen ihre Website
mal angucken und ein bisschen schauen, ob man vielleicht
schon rauskriegt, was sie so machen.
Also sind die eher AWS
heavy, Google Cloud,
Azure, wie auch immer
angelegt und vielleicht
mal so einen
so einen
Overview-Kurs zu Kubernetes
kannst du dir auch angucken, weil das ja
dann zu deinen Hauptaufgaben zählt.
Da kannst du ein bisschen mit
Know-How glänzen, kannst du denen sagen,
ja, der Unterschied zwischen nem Pot
und nem Container und sowas in der Richtung.
Ansonsten, keine Ahnung,
was sie fragen könnten.
Max, hab endlich mein Wirtschaftsinformatikzeug
in der Tasche, auf geht's ins
DevOps.
Ja, dann. GLHF.
Also, ich
hab geantwortet, Windows administrieren müssen,
aber das hat er nicht gelten lassen.
So, dieses Video
wurde mir vorhin empfohlen. Warum
Softwareentwickler selten Karriere machen,
Chat-Gem, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, ich kann euch sagen,
ich bin ja kein Hauptberuflicher Softwareentwickler, danke schön
für den Sub.
SAP-Consultant, ja, wenn
du richtig fett Kohle machen willst, ich weiß
nicht, ob man was können muss als SAP-Consultant.
Ich kenn mich selber zu wenig mit
SAP aus, um einschätzen zu können,
ob die SAP-Consultants,
mit denen ich bisher was zu tun hatte,
auch Ahnung haben, ob das
gute SAP-Consultants sind.
Das weiß ich nicht, aber
SAP
ist so ein Thema.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die
hörst du eigentlich relativ selten in der IT.
Das ist zum Beispiel,
mit SAP haben wir Geld gespart,
oder mit Oracle haben wir Geld
gespart. Also, in der
Regel kostet eigentlich SAP
und Oracle nur extra.
Also,
richtig viel und sie haben
super eklige Lizenzbestimmungen
bei Oracle. Bei SAP weiß
ich nicht so sehr, aber Oracle hat so
ziemlich die beschissensten Lizenzbedingungen, die es
gibt.
Beispielsweise auch ihre
Mindestsupport-Status,
den du haben musst für alle Produkte,
wenn du eins gekauft hast und sowas. Ganz, ganz
weh, was Oracle da treibt.
Also, Oracle hat wirklich
eine
Lizenzpolitik, die
zum Vermeiden von weiteren
Oracle-Käufen beiträgt.
Und außerdem
ist der Oracle-Support auch maximal
useless, zumindest was ich bisher von gesehen habe.
Will ich allgemein sagen.
Aber die Tickets, die ich bisher bei Oracle gesehen
habe, sind meistens voll für den Arsch gewesen.
Die einzigen, die noch schlimmer sind,
was Support-Fälle sind, ist
Microsoft für Azure.
Da habe ich schon Dinge,
also, ganz ehrlich, die Microsoft-Support-
Fälle sind so unglaublich bescheuert
gewesen, bisher, was ich gesehen habe.
Machst ein Ticket
auf,
bla bla bla bla, wird Traffic
getroppt und kriegst
als Antwort,
wir haben verstanden, sie haben
ein Problem damit, dass
im Setting XY,
bei aktiviertem Setting XY
Traffic
getroppt wird. Bitte versuchen sie
folgendes, schalten sie die Diagnose-
Funktion ein. Wenn das Problem behoben
ist, dann schließen sie bitte das Ticket.
Was ich über
VMware gehört habe, in letzter Zeit
wenig. Auf der alten Arbeit,
wo ich zumindest noch ein bisschen
was mitgekriegt habe von den VMware-Leuten,
wurde da zwar auch öfters geflamed
über den VMware-Support, aber
im Großen und Ganzen
scheinen die halbwegs damit zufrieden
gewesen zu sein.
Ich habe letztens den unsinnigsten,
ich komme leider nicht mehr drauf,
was es war, bei Apple.
Kennt ihr dieses Apple-Support-Forum?
Wo dann immer irgendwelche
Inder oder
keine Ahnung, wie nennt man das?
Clickworker, arbeiten
und nichts sinnvolles
schreiben, als
offizielle Response.
Ich habe bei Apple, nach was habe ich denn
bei Apple letztens gesucht?
Ich habe gesucht nach...
Also die Antwort war, geht nicht,
aber auch nicht so richtig.
Ich habe gesucht nach...
Wie kann man...
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Apple-Support ist wirklich richtig Müll.
Was habe ich denn gesucht?
Was wollte ich denn aufmachen?
Es muss auf jeden Fall was mit meinem
iPhone zu tun haben.
Ich wollte irgendwas
Apple...
Irgendwie wie man Shortcuts im Background
laufen lassen kann.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was.
Aber das habe ich glaube ich nicht gesucht.
Und die Antwort war so
unglaublich dumm in diesem Support-Forum.
Und es war ein offizieller Apple-Typ.
Die wurden einfach nur gepostet,
dass man sich sagen konnte, sie reagieren drauf.
Ich mache einen riesen Bogen
um iCloud. Ich benutze iCloud für nichts.
Ich habe den iCloud-Sync für alles ausgeschaltet.
Tatsächlich die aller einzigste
Funktion die ich von iCloud benutze
ist find my device.
Beziehungsweise find my
Bekanntschaft so.
Und ich habe auch nicht vor
irgendwas iCloud mäßig zu benutzen.
Wieso meiden?
Weil es sich immer weiter
lockend
in das Apple-Ökosystem.
Wie ist deine Erfahrung mit externen
Konsultants die bei dir mit im Team arbeiten?
Es kommt auf den Konsultant an.
Also
ich habe schon jede Menge
unfähiger Konsultants erlebt.
Wo ich mich frage, zu was soll ich den überhaupt
konsultieren?
In diesem Namen Konsultant
schwingt ja eigentlich, zumindest für mich
mit, das ist jemand
wenn ich selbst nicht weiter weiß
dann kann ich den konsultieren.
Dann kann ich den fragen.
Also die weit weit weit
überwiegende Zahl der Fälle
habe ich mich gefragt
was will ich den Konsultant eigentlich fragen?
Bei was kann der mir eigentlich helfen?
Wir hatten mal einen
Ich überlege gerade wie das
gewesen ist.
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Wir hatten mal einen externen Konsultant
bei uns, der hat irgendwie zwei Wochen gebraucht
sein Notebook einzurichten.
Wo ich auch gedacht habe, was
macht der so lang?
Auf einmal kam er dann zu mir
und meinte so, ja Max ich habe gehört
du kümmerst dich ja hier um unsere Git Repos
erklär mir doch mal wie ich das
jetzt mache mit dem Git.
Da habe ich ihn erst mal blöd angeguckt
und
hab dann gemeint
ich meine eigentlich so halb
aus Spaß habe ich zu ihm gesagt
wie jetzt?
Ich dachte als externer Experte
kannst du mir das jetzt erklären?
Da hat er gleich zurückgeruht
aber natürlich
ich habe ihm dann gezeigt
wie er sich einloggen kann
wo er die Repos findet
und sowas.
Er hat es mit Shit aber nicht so
gehabt.
Und da denke ich mir halt
also
die meist verbreitetsten
aktuellen Technologien
die eigentlich nahezu jeder Firma
benutzt werden, die kann man
als Experte doch schon erwarten
zu haben oder?
Ja das ist
meine Erfahrung
mit Consultants.
Gibt aber auch
positive Beispiele
beispielsweise
einer
auf meiner neuen Arbeit
der ist eingekauft
für so Cloud
Security Kubernetes Geschichten
und der hat auch wirklich Ahnung.
Ich habe mir sogar schon überlegt
ob ich mit dem mal nicht
einen Stream hier mache oder ob wir
ein Video aufnehmen sollen
also Video weniger aber
einen Stream wo er uns zeigen kann
wie man seinen selbst
aufgesetzten Kubernetes Cluster ordentlich
gegen Hackermens absichert.
Aber ich weiß nicht ob wir das irgendwie hinkriegen.
Dankeschön für den Sub
High IQ Subscription Leute.
Way too smart.
Zack B Training
Was ist Isaac B
International Software Architecture
Qualification Board
Boah da sind schon so viele Sachen
aneinandergereiht, dass ich da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf hätte.
Man kann sich für Software
Architektur zertifizieren.
Das ist doch auch wieder so ein selbsterhaltendes Ökosystem
oder?
Chetke ich kenne diese Zertifizierung nicht.
Taugt das?
Ich habe die Zertifizierung immer relativ negativ
eingestellt, weil das
meistens so ein in sich selbsterhaltendes
Geldbeschaffungssystem ist.
Doch ich bin jetzt Agile
ich habe ein Fahrrad.
Doch sehe ich genauso.
Das ist eines der wichtigsten Skills
eines
jeden Informatikors
dass der ordentlich Suchmaschinen
bedienen kann.
Okay
Also die sinnloseste Prüfung
äh nicht Prüfung
sinnloseste Schulung die ich in letzter Zeit machen müsste
das war aber noch beim alten Arbeitgeber
war irgendeine Azure Admin Schulung
da wurde
ein offizieller Microsoft
zertifizierter Trainer machen
und der hat dann nur offizielle PowerPoint Sachen
durchgeklickt für 2 oder 3 Tage
das war mega lahm und hat nichts gebracht.
Meinst du Google wird mal wieder besser?
Im großen und ganzen
ist Google eigentlich noch ziemlich gut.
Ich muss aber sagen
ich benutze in letzter Zeit vermehrt DuckDuckGo
Letzter Zeit ist
dehnbar seit den letzten Jahren über schon.
Aber DuckDuckGo
ist auch nice.
Wobei ich gar nicht weiß
was DuckDuckGo drunter benutzt
benutzen die nicht Bing?
Oder sowas?
Oder indexen die selbst? Das glaube ich kaum.
Die benutzen auch Google
Okay
Aber die finde ich
schon seit den letzten paar Jahren
alles gut
Microsoft wollte Bing an Apple
verkaufen?
Naja gut, warum nicht?
Google wollte Google auch an Yahoo verkaufen
damals. Wie das ausgegangen ist
weiß man ja heute.
Google gibt es noch, Yahoo gibt
wobei
gibt es die noch?
Althaba
die gibt es nicht mehr
Nun gut
Das Video wurde mir heute empfohlen
Warum Softwareentwickler selten Karriere machen
Ich meine ich bin kein Software
Ich bin zwar Softwareentwickler
aber ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Softwareentwickler
Also man könnte sagen
kein Professional
der damit seinen Lebensunterhalt verdient
Aber ich gehe davon aus
dass die Gründe
warum Softwareentwickler selten Karriere machen
so diesen klassischen
Karrieregrind so nach dem Motto
Irgendwann werde ich Teamleiter
dann werde ich Abteilungsteilnehmer
und dann greife ich keinen Bock drauf
auf den Scheiß
Als Softwareentwickler verdient man genug
also man verdient eindeutig
über der Schwelle wo man sich Sorgen machen muss
und dann muss man sich halt fragen
will man sich den zusätzlichen Stress
und den ganzen Scheiß der damit zusammenhängt
noch geben oder nicht
und dementsprechend
gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von mir aus
was das Thema Karriere machen angeht
Ihr wisst ich bin ein richtig krasser Karrieregrinder
Ich
Ich grinde so hart die Karriere
dass das
schon wieder bei Null angekommen ist
und dementsprechend ich habe auch keinen Bock
Ich habe keinen Bock
auf klassische Karriere
Das liegt daran weil ich erstens
das gerne mache was ich mache
und ich überhaupt keinen Bock
darauf habe irgendwas
mit Personalverantwortung
oder
Projektmanagement oder sowas
zu machen
Das ist ja so der klassische Karriereweg
den viele so für sich
für sich
so sehen irgendwie
so nach dem Motto ja erstmal mache ich das
dann mache ich vielleicht ein bisschen Projektmanagement
dann mache ich irgendwann mal Teamleitung
also mein alter Chef hat mir mal gesagt
dass
es eigentlich falsch ist
wenn man einen
Teamleiter Manager nennt
aus seiner Sicht
Er hat gesagt
für ihn ist quasi so klassisches
Management und Mitarbeiterführung
eigentlich zwei grundsätzlich unterschiedliche
Dinger auch wenn es oftmals
unter Management zusammengefasst wird
okay klingt nicht schlecht
aber das ist
nichts für mich und das war lange Zeit
leider so ziemlich der einzige
Karriereweg den viele Unternehmen geboten
haben so nach dem Motto machst mal ein bisschen
Projekt zeigst mal was du geiles kannst
dann wirst du vielleicht mal Teamleiter
mal Abteilungsleiter und mal was auch immer
sonst noch so für Positionen dazwischen sind
und da haben viele keinen Bock drauf
und daraufhin
haben jetzt ja viele Unternehmen realisiert
dass das gerade für Techniker
nicht so geil ist und die da eigentlich keinen Bock drauf haben
weil warum sollte man das machen
sich freiwillig fertig machen
obwohl man ja das andere was man sonst macht viel lieber macht
deswegen gibt es jetzt meistens noch
neben diesen klassischen
Karrieremöglichkeiten
noch so eine zweite Technik
Karrieremöglichkeit wo sich manche Unternehmen
schwer damit tun sowas zu implementieren
aber da gibt es dann meistens sowas wie
Experte
Architekt
oder was auch immer da kannst du dann noch so ein bisschen
steigern das ganze
und hast dann
zwar auch mehr Verantwortung
aber eben nicht
solche Management und
Personalführung Sachen
das ist was was ich mir
beschränkt noch irgendwie
vorstellen könnte aber ehrlich gesagt
ich glaube ich bin am besten
wenn ich
kann der Firma am besten was
für mein Geld
bieten wenn ich Technikgramm mache und wenn die
mich Technikgramm machen lassen
was mich bei einer aktuellen Firma auch
sagen wir mal
naja ganz okay
machen lässt der Meetinganteil ist halt
unnötig hoch das habe ich auch schon
500 mal gesagt aber das ist halt so
ich meine ich sitze auch 50%
meiner Arbeitstag
ich sitze auch 50% meiner Arbeitszeit
in irgendwelchen sinnlosen Meetings wo ich nicht
ein Wort sagen muss
ist okay wenn die das wollen und mir dafür
fett Kohle bezahlen soll mir das recht sein
aber ich finde es natürlich ein bisschen doof weil ich lieber
was anderes machen würde
also so eine
so eine Experten Architekten Sache
könnte ich mir eventuell
irgendwann mal vorstellen aber
eher nicht ehrlich gesagt
eher nicht das müsste natürlich schon
ganz das wirklich perfekte
Gebiet sein und
ich müsste irgendwie
weiß ich nicht bisschen bisschen
Bock da drauf kriegen
ich glaube nicht ganz ehrlich
die Position die ich jetzt hab
vollkommen in Ordnung
ich kann mit technischem Knowhow
glänzen
beziehungsweise damit das machen
also ich werde für mein
technisches Knowhow bezahlen und das ist eigentlich
das was ich haben will
und letztendlich will ich ansonsten auch gar nichts
großartig machen es gibt genug Kohle
dafür es wird in Zukunft wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
mehr Kohle geben unter anderem
auch daran weil es nach wie vor immer
schwieriger werden wird Leute zu finden
gerade wenn du
spezifische Sachen
haben willst mit längerer
gepaart mit längerer Berufserfahrung
wird es wahrscheinlich auch langfristig
noch mehr Kohle geben das heißt warum
sollte ich irgendwas anderes machen
die bezahlen jetzt schon richtig nice
warum sollte ich noch mehr machen
warum sollte ich mir noch mehr Stress geben
für ein paar Euro
mehr
dann lieber weniger Stress
trotzdem gut auskommen
und möglichst viel das machen worauf
man Bock hat so das ist das was ich mir denke
wenn es um das Thema Karriere machen geht
Hi Fenix Dankeschön für den Sub
Ist die Cam in Meetings immer an?
Nö
Also auf meinen Meetings ist die Kamera
standardmäßig
nur in unserem
Projekt
Daily an und selbst da habe ich
sie nicht immer an
ansonsten manchmal zum Winken
wenn ich irgendjemanden schon eine Weile nicht mehr gehört habe
aber ansonsten habe ich die Kamera eigentlich
aus gerade wenn man sich irgendwelche
Sachen zusammen anguckt entweder
shared einer der Desktop einer guckt
beim anderen oder man redet über irgendwas
da muss man sich nicht sehen dabei
sehe ich genauso aber es checken
immer mehr richtig
ja ich sehe das genauso
es sind einfach viele Techniker
und das darf man auch nicht vergessen
viele Techniker sind keine
guten Führungskräfte klar kannst
jetzt sagen es gibt Führungskräfte Ausbildung
Führungskräfte Coaching und sowas
aber du musst schon die richtige
der richtige Typ dafür sein das ist das
ich glaube nicht
dass du es sonst jemals richtig
hundertprozentig überzeugend hinbekommst
und jedes Mal
wenn du dich dazu überwinden musst
was zu machen was dir innerlich
widerstrebt dann ist es einfach keine
richtige Position für dich
und es sind viele Manager
keine guten ITler und viele
gute ITler sind keine guten Manager
so und
manchmal
kommt es ja so über
zusammen dann hast du welche
aber es ist nicht schlimm jeder hat so seine eigenen
Stärken
ja und wenn es die Firma
erlaubt kann man ja in so eine Richtung gehen
dann gibt es auch ein bisschen mehr Kohle mehr
Verantwortung aber zumindest
nichts was mit Personal zu tun hat
ne warum?
Zeig doch mal ich lese immer gerne
übertriebene Stellenanzeigen
und viele Führungskräfte sind keine
guten Führungskräfte ja kommt auch noch dazu
ja
ich mein
es gibt auch
viele Leute die in der IT arbeiten wo ich mich frage
das ist ja überall so
also ich würde sagen 80
90% der Leute sind
zwischen
sie haben überhaupt keinen Plan von dem was sie machen
bis zu
ja Standardzeug können sie ganz gut
erledigen und die restlichen 10%
sind halt die die du haben willst eigentlich
zumindest für Positionen
wo man Ahnung haben
muss und keine Scheiße bauen sollte
es gab es gab mal so eine coole
ich weiß nicht mal wo ich das hier hab
ich hab mal ein Video gesehen
irgendein Konferenz Talk
da hat einer
so eine Tabelle gebaut
oh Moment
mal kurz
überskippen
da hat einer so eine Tabelle
gebaut so und
wo ist er hier
ich bin mir da nicht so sicher ob ich das
jetzt hin
richtig hinbekomme
ähm
so das hier war glaube ich
ja
hohe Motivation
oder sowas
niedrige Motivation
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das so richtig hinbekomme
so ähm
oder sag mal
hoher nennen wir es mal anders
nennen wir es mal
hoher Einsatz
oder oder oder
Einsatz
also Antrieb ja meine ich jetzt
so ähm
so und
hier oben stand
was war denn das
Skill
also
äh
also hat Ahnung
hat
keine Ahnung
so und
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das jetzt zusammenkriege
zumindest hat er gesagt
in diesem Vortrag
das war auch ein bisschen auf lustig gemacht aber ich finde das
klang schon eindeutig
der hat gesagt diese Kombination hier
ist mega selten
das sind die Leute
die willst du eigentlich
quasi für immer
für immer bei dir behalten
und das
so angenehm wie möglich machen
weil das sind Leute die schaffen viel
die machen wenig
kaputt weil sie Ahnung haben
und und kriegen insgesamt viel
so viel auf die Reihe
dann gibt es Leute
die haben Ahnung
und wenig zeigen wenig Einsatz
die willst du auch haben weil
die haben meistens ziemlich gute Lösungen
weil sie faul sind
faule Leute haben die besten Lösungen
dann hast du Leute
die zeigen wenig Einsatz
aber
haben auch keine Ahnung
da kann man
ein paar von haben das ist nicht so wild
die kannst du
Dinger machen lassen so einfache Sachen
und so aber
das ist nicht so schlimm die allerschlimmsten
sind die hier
hoher Einsatz und keine Ahnung
man würde
eigentlich denken das hier sind die schlimmsten
aber nein das hier sind die schlimmsten
weil die machen dir
alles kaputt
die sind laufend am machen
haben aber keinen Plan in dem was sie machen
und das sind die allerschlimmsten
und wenn du sowas
im Management sitzen hast
dann hast du richtig die Arschkarte
wenn du so einen übereifrigen
Manager hast der absolut keinen Plan
von seinem Job hat
dann hast du echt ein Problem
und ich finde ich weiß
nicht mehr aus welchem Vortrag ich die Tabelle hab
Tabelle diese Grafik
das hab ich in irgendeinem
in irgendeinem Youtube Konferenz
Talk gesehen ich fand das hat
eigentlich wirklich ganz gut getroffen
ja
ja das ist doch meistens so
dass die Leute die von sich meinen
sie haben es am krassesten drauf
zwar Ausnahmen
gibt von Leuten die es wirklich krass drauf
haben aber in der Regel ist die Kombination
es krass drauf haben
plus
so super offensiv allen
zu erzählen man hat es krass drauf
doch relativ selten
weil es gibt ja diese
schöne Grafik so
mit steigendem Knowledge
fällt aber auch immer mehr auf
wie kompliziert der ganze Scheiß eigentlich ist und was es noch
alles gibt wovon man keine Ahnung hat
ich finde es viel sinniger
wenn man was gescheites macht
es muss ja auch gar nicht viel sein
man muss halt ab und zu mal was wirklich gutes gescheites
machen und das kann man
dann auch breittreten überall
dass alle mitkriegen
dass man mal richtig was geiles gemacht hat
das reicht ja eigentlich schon
tja das gibt es viele die an der falschen
Position sitzen die selbst dann aber auch
manchmal total unglücklich sind an der Position
ja
aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal das eigentliche Video an was ich mir angucken will
das waren jetzt meine Gedanken dazu
und jetzt gucken wir mal an
was in diesem Video erzählt wird
Moment
Alter das ist ne Mega Idee
Leute ich brauch doch ab und zu mal
irgendwie halbwegs sinniges Hintergrund
Footage für meine Videos
ja ich rede ja auch über so random Zeug in meinen Videos
ich papp mir einfach aufs Fahrrad
ne GoPro
fahr ein bisschen durch den Wald
über die Wiese und mach 15 Minuten
sinnlose Fahrrad GoPro Footage
hinter das Video
und erzähl euch dann irgendwas über
Führungskräfte in der IT
und warum ich
mit manchen schon gezofft habe
oder warum ich manche gut und schlecht finde
ist dann quasi
Naturstelz 2.0
Ist das so?
Also Leute
ich hatte von Anfang an den Karriereplan
keine Karriere zu machen
Wusstet ihr das?
Chat stimmt das?
Habt ihr am Anfang gedacht
oh in 5 Jahren will ich Teamleiter sein
oder sowas?
Ich nie. Ich hab mir immer nur gedacht
lasst mich mit dem Scheiß in Ruhe
Hattest du? Okay.
Gibt ja welche
die haben die Absicht
und machen dann jahrelang den übelsten Grind
beziehungsweise stellen vielleicht
dann auch irgendwann fest
dass es keine so gute Idee gewesen
Aber kannst du nicht die Führungskraft übernehmen
dann siehst du dass es nicht so leicht ist
Hä?
Das bezieht sich nicht auf mich oder?
Also ich wie gesagt
ich hab da auch überhaupt keine Ambition
das war letztens schon wieder auf der Arbeit lustig
also bei uns wurde eine
Stelle ausgeschrieben für irgendeine
Teamleiterposition
und
ich hab unseren
IT-Chef auf irgendeinem Meeting
gefragt so
also warum ich
gefragt hab, der Hintergrund war
ich kenne vielleicht
jemand der für diese Stelle passt
so, das war meine Hintergedanken
und da hab ich gefragt, sag mal
wie ist denn das
wann werden solche Stellen denn hier extern
ausgeschrieben
und wie läuft
das hier mit Bewerbungsprozess
ich bin ja noch neu dabei
würd mich einfach mal interessieren und dann meint er
jeder kann sich bewerben, Max du kannst dich ja auch da drauf
bewerben und dann musste ich gleich
sagen, ne ne ne ne
nicht dass man mich jetzt falsch versteht
ich hab überhaupt keine Ambition
da drauf zu bewerben
würd schon gleich, gleich wirst du verhaftet
ok
auf gehts, hören wir uns jetzt nochmal an
wenn Softwareentwickler in den Berufsalltag
starten, haben sie meistens einen relativ festen
Karriereplan, sie wissen wann möchten sie was erreichen
welche Rolle wollen sie vielleicht bekleiden
und natürlich auch am Ende, was wollen sie für ein Gehalt
verdienen. In der Praxis erlebe ich es aber ganz oft
dass die Softwareentwickler sich dann doch umentscheiden
und irgendwann .NET
der ist mir schon mal sympathisch
doch keine Karriere mehr machen wollen, egal welcher
Posten winkt, egal welches Gehalt winkt
sie wollen einfach Softwareentwickler bleiben
und genau das ist der Inhalt des heutigen Videos
nicht nur Softwareentwickler, das ist im Prinzip ja genau das
was ich im Vorfeld erzählt hab
wir werden uns mal anschauen warum das ganze so ist
denn ich hab da eine Theorie
aber mehr dazu nach dem Intro, viel Spaß
wupp wupp wupp
naja, nicht so wupp wupp wupp wie ich gedacht hab
ich hab am Anfang der Woche den Anruf eines
Geschäftsführers bekommen, einer meiner Kunden
der mir gesagt hat, dass am Ende des Jahres
der Leiter leider das Unternehmen verlassen wird
und er hat dann
versucht mit den Entwicklern zusammen eine Lösung
zu finden, also mit den Entwicklern zu sprechen, wer
diesen Posten übernehmen möchte
und er hat dann mit den Sätzen festgestellt, keiner der Entwickler
wollte es am Ende des Tages machen
das kann ich gut nachvollziehen
Michael 50 Billiarden, nice, Subscription
Dankeschön
und für dich extra
weil du es bist
das kann ich gut nachvollziehen
im letzten Laden, wo ich gearbeitet hab
da war das auch so
immer wenn Teamleiter oder noch mehr
Abteilungsleiter, was auch immer, Positionen
frei geworden sind
und sie Bewerber dafür intern sammeln wollten
es haben alle immer gesagt
geh mir mit dem Scheiß weg
ich will es auf gar keinen Fall machen
das lag aber auch daran, weil die wussten
was das für eine Scheiß-Position ist
wir hatten bei uns sogar Teamleiter
die sind zurückgetreten
habt ihr das schon mal erlebt, Leute?
dass
ein Großteil
der Teamleiter
das nur feststellt
sie wollen das, dass sie zurücktreten vom Teamleiter
sein
also das ist in der alten Firma, wo ich war
tatsächlich öfters vorgekommen
und irgendwann, es wollte
niemand mehr machen, die haben einfach
keine Leute gefunden, die das machen wollen
und
das ist tatsächlich das Kontrastprogramm
zu dort, wo ich
jetzt arbeite, was tatsächlich
eher auch für den neuen Arbeitgeber spricht
dort haben die ein
internes
Führungskräfte-Förderungsprogramm
das heißt
da wird keiner ins kalte Wasser geschmissen
so nach dem Motto
es ist jetzt eine Führungsposition frei
wir brauchen da jemand, hat jemand Bock
nein, das ist so, du kannst sagen
das ist was, was ich gerne machen würde
und dann machst
du
zwei, drei Jahre
kannst du dann nicht im Voraus quasi schon
bewerben oder
anmelden für sowas
du musst es im Endeffekt dann auch nie machen, wenn du nicht willst
aber du kriegst dann zumindest schon mal die
Basic-Ausbildung für Führungskräfte
da kriegst du dann so Sachen
wahrscheinlich beigebracht
wie geht man mit Mitarbeiter in Stresssituationen
um, bla bla bla
was auch immer, ich weiß es nicht, was man da genau macht
weil ich hab mich da nie beworben und ich hab's auch nicht vor
das Programm zu machen
und wenn dann mal eine Position
frei wird
dann haben wir tatsächlich intern Leute, die
sagen, ja, ich will das machen
und ich bin nicht total unprepared
und planlos, weil ich die letzten
zwei, drei oder was weiß ich schon
die interne Führungskräfte-Ausbildung
gemacht hab, das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
relativ sinnvoll, beim letzten Arbeitgeber
haben alle immer gesagt, oh nee, hau mal ab
will ich nicht machen
kannst du kurz zeigen, welches
Rad du jetzt gekauft hast
wie gut, dass ich das noch im Hintergrund
auf hab, weil du bist nicht der Erste, der heute gefragt hat
das da hab ich mir gekauft
die Farbe sieht aber in echt anders aus
als auf dem Bild
das ist Alu, ne, das ist Carbon
eigentlich komplett unsinnig, so viel Geld
auszugeben für so ein Einsteiger-Ding, aber
irgendwo muss die Kohle ja hin
ich kann nicht alles
in den ETF stecken
Stonks
das Coole an dem Fahrrad ist
Carbon-Lenker
Alu-Rahmen
Tubeless-Reifen
elektronische Schaltungen
also du hast schon coole Sachen dabei
nichts was man als Einsteiger wirklich braucht
aber
nice
Kam das fertig montiert an?
Nicht alles
was man machen muss am Ende
ist Lieferzeit ungefähr
eine Woche
nicht mal ganz, 5-6 Tage
ich hab das
ich glaube ich hab das mittwochs bestellt
und dienstags die Woche
drauf kam es, also ja 6 Tage
oder sowas
kannst du einen Link posten, steht doch schon im Chat drin
und
das wollte ich jetzt noch sagen
ja, was ich
mega nice finde, für mich
als Bustlose ist ja
ich hab hier vorne so einen kleinen Fahrradcomputer drauf
man kann die Schaltung
diese
Di2 oder wie man das ausspricht
man kann die Schaltung koppeln
mit seiner Fitness-Uhr
mit seinem Fitness-Tracker oder mit dem
Fahrradcomputer oder auch
mit dem Smartphone
und das ist natürlich mit dem Smartphone
kannst du dann, du kannst quasi deine Schaltung
Firmware updaten mit dem Smartphone
das weiß ich, hab ich noch nicht gemacht
was ich viel cooler finde
ist die Schaltung zu koppeln
mit dem
Fahrradcomputer
da siehst du dann zum Beispiel auch
den Gang du gerade bist, weil
du hast ja hier nichts, außer einen Hebel
also die Gänge schaltet man hier mit
hier schaltest du hoch, also hier wird es schwerer
weiß nicht, ob man das hoch oder runter schalten nennt
also hier schaltest du
hoch, also hier wird es schwerer und hier schaltest du
runter
oder umgedreht, wie auch immer
hier, dass es leichter wird
an dem Hebel
das ist die Bremse, aber hier schaltet man das
und
hier innen drin hat man noch zwei Knöpfe
und die kann man mappen
auf sein Fahrradcomputer
zum Beispiel, dass der Fahrradcomputer
den Batteriestand von der Schaltung anzeigt
und den aktuellen Gang
auf der Tour de France fahren die nicht
mit solchen komischen Fahrrädern hier
ähm
so, was wollte ich jetzt
sagen
ja, und die Buttons hier oben
kannst du dir mappen
wireless auf dein
Fahrradcomputer und dann kannst du dann damit
zum Beispiel die Seiten auf deinem Fahrradcomputer
durchschalten, so, beispielsweise
von der Statistikseite auf die Map-Seite
und dann auf die
Anstiegsseite, was auch immer
kannst du mit den
Knöpfen hier oben machen
Spritzschutz und Beleuchtung
also irgendwelche Schutzbleche
kann man anbringen, hat der hier
Montagepunkte und sowas
kann man machen
bieten die sogar an, die bieten sogar eins fertig
mit Gepäckträger und Schutzblechen an
aber brauche ich nicht, also ich habe keine
Gepäckträger, keine Schutzbleche dran
was ich dran habe ist
ich habe ein Reflektor hinten dran
und ich habe
ein Rücklicht dran
ob man da ein Fahrradständer dran machen
kann, keine Ahnung, vielleicht hier unten
ok, guck mal weiter
eigentlich brauchen wir uns das Video angucken
lul
der Lenker ist nicht gut für den Rücken, das geht
das geht besser
als ich gedacht habe, ich hatte ja selbst
so meine Bedenken
dass man da ein bisschen
gar zu
tief sitzt
das ist aber gar kein großes Ding, das ist ok
also die Sitzposition
also Rückenprobleme habe ich
tatsächlich gar keine, mir tut der Arsch weh
und ich bin
ich hänge mich noch viel zu sehr in die Arme vorne
auf dem Lenker
aber rückenmäßig ist überhaupt
kein Problem
das geht
das geht tatsächlich ganz gut
es ist sogar noch deutlich bequemer finde ich
wenn man hier ganz runtergreift
also am bequemsten
ist natürlich hier oben drauf
ich finde es teilweise auch
echt entspannt, weil man sich mal ein bisschen
vorhängen kann da drauf
also ich finde
das nice bis jetzt
ich bin ja wie gesagt noch nicht groß gefahren
also ich bin
gestern 25
und heute
32 Kilometer gefahren
warum ich das gleichzeitig benutze, ja
mehr Browser zur Ausfahrt
ich habe auch noch Firefox
also gucken wir uns mal das Video an
das ist ja stehen geblieben
ups
ja der Abteilungsleiter hat vielleicht das Unternehmen
verlassen, weil er weiß, dass es irgendein komischer
Laden ist, bei dem er nicht länger bleiben will, man weiß ja nie
ne, was ja auch
dafür sprechen würde, dass keiner der anderen Entwickler
Bock hat, das zu machen
versucht mit den Entwicklern zusammen eine Lösung zu finden
also mit den Entwicklern zu sprechen, wer diesen Posten übernehmen
möchte und er hat dann mit den Sätzen festgestellt
keiner der Entwickler wollte es am Ende des
Tages machen und solche
Situationen oder ähnliche Situationen erlebe
ich immer wieder, zum Beispiel wenn ich Architektur
Workshops gebe, ist es meistens so, dass
das Team aktuell noch keinen Architekten hat
am Anfang wollen alle Architekt werden
alle finden das ganz toll
was macht er jetzt mit der Kamera, wenn er vorne angekommen ist
und wenn dann klar ist, was alles mit
dieser Rolle verbunden ist, was die Aufgaben sind
was die Verantwortung sind, will das plötzlich keiner
mehr machen. Andere Situation ist
wenn ich Prozessreviews mache
wird oft festgestellt, dass genau diese extrem wichtige
Rolle des Scrum Masters, des Change Managers
nicht besetzt ist. Da kann man sich
jetzt drüber schreiten, ob Scrum Master
ein Change Manager sein soll
da kann man sich sicherlich im Agile
Umfeld stundenlang drüber
unterhalten. Chat
ja das habe ich schon, das habe ich schon
ausprobiert, ich kann es aber nicht
nutzen für alle
Anwendungszwecke, weil ich gerne
Plattform I.O. verwende
für Microcontroller
und das braucht die offizielle
C++ Extension für Visual Studio Code
und die gibt es nur, zumindest war
das das letzte Mal, dass ich geguckt habe
nur für das offizielle
Visual Studio Code, weil da proprietärer
Microsoft Shit drin ist
Erkennen das Problem und verstehen
das Problem, wenn es aber darum geht, wer
jetzt diese Rolle übernehmen möchte
zurücktreten möchte, ein Stück weit
und diese Rolle Scrum Master übernehmen möchte, dann will das
plötzlich irgendwie keiner mehr machen. Ja
und versteht mich bei der Sache jetzt nicht falsch, es ist natürlich
am Ende immer so, ich habe euch ja schon erklärt
was ich dazu denke
Irgendwer findet sich das schon notfalls, wird von externen
neue Personalien geholt, die diese Rolle dann
begleitet, aber man sieht es halt, diese
vakanten Positionen liegen
im Unternehmen rum, es würde mehr Anerkennung
bedeuten, mehr Gehalt, mehr Verantwortung
und die Software... Vor allem
würde es, okay es mag
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Gehalt, je nachdem
wie groß der Sprung ist ja von Unternehmen zu
Unternehmen unterschiedlich, es mag mehr
Gehalt bedeuten, es mag eventuell
mehr Anerkennung bedeuten, ist die Frage
von wem
aber es bedeutet
auch unglaublich
viel dummes Zeug, mit dem man sich
auseinandersetzen muss und Stress
den man sich aussetzt
den man sich ansonsten einfach
nicht aussetzen müsste
Entwickler wollen diese Chance
einfach irgendwie nicht ergreifen
Als nächstes stellt sich natürlich die Frage, welche Karrieremöglichkeiten
habe ich überhaupt in der Softwareentwicklung
und ich denke wir müssen unterscheiden auch mal in die
Karrieremöglichkeiten innerhalb des Teams
und außerhalb des Teams, also in der Unternehmensorganisation
Innerhalb des Teams können wir
Rollen bekleiden, wo wir für das Team
und für das Produkt mehr Verantwortung übernehmen können
wie gerade zum Beispiel angesprochen, der Architekt
verantwortet die Struktur innerhalb von so einem Unternehmen
braucht meistens mehr Wissen, braucht mehr
Ausbildung, bekommt dementsprechend meistens auch
mehr Gehalt. Auf der anderen Seite, gerade auch angesprochen
das Scrum Master ist für den Prozess verantwortlich
für die stetige Fortentwicklung des Prozesses
auch hier wieder mehr Verantwortung
also auch mehr Gehalt. Aber auch solche Dinge
wie DevOps zum Beispiel sind meistens Zusatzqualifikation
neben der normalen Entwicklung
wo derjenige, der diese Rolle bekleidet
die Verantwortung übernimmt für den Bereitstellungsprozess
also dass das Produkt am Ende
auch tatsächlich da landet, wo es
in Betrieb genommen werden soll. Als nächstes
kann man natürlich innerhalb der Unternehmensorganisation
innerhalb der Unternehmenshierarchie weiter
aufsteigen und das unterscheidet sich natürlich sehr sehr stark
von Unternehmen zu Unternehmen, aber wir schauen uns mal
die Level an, die man in den
meisten Unternehmen wiederfindet. Das erste ist
natürlich der Teamleiter. Der Teamleiter ist derjenige
der... Ja gut, das habe ich ja
gerade auch schon erzählt, also
das ist glaube ich überall, mehr oder weniger
die Personalverantwortung für das Team hat, der also
disziplinarisch dieses Team führt. Ja, dann hast
du irgendwie noch so Gruppenleiter, Abteilungsleiter
oder vielleicht dann noch irgendeinen
Direktor oder was auch immer. Das ist immer ein bisschen
unterschiedlich. Dass das Team sich weiterentwickelt
dass es dem Team gut geht und so weiter
und so fort. Darüber ist meistens der sogenannte
Abteilungsleiter. Der Abteilungsleiter
hat mehrere Teams unter sich und
diese Teams sind meistens fachlich irgendwie
gruppiert. Das heißt, wir haben ein Entwicklungsteam,
vielleicht ein Bereitstellungsteam, ein Team für die Infrastruktur
und die wird eben verwaltet, geleitet
von genau diesem Abteilungsleiter. Wieder
mehr Verantwortung und natürlich am Ende
des Tages auch mehr Gehalt. Nächste Ebene, darüber
findet man oft den Hauptabteilungsleiter
oder den Bereichsleiter, der sehr sehr viele
Abteilungen unter sich hat, die wieder
zu einer thematischen Gruppierung gehören.
Politik zum Beispiel oder Risiko oder sonst
irgendwelche Dinge. Das heißt, der hat dieselbe
Verantwortung. Er verwaltet quasi diese
Abteilung, managt diese Verwaltung, kümmert
sich um die Mitarbeiter, um die Strategie davon
und so weiter. Auch hier wieder mehr Verantwortung,
mehr Gehalt. Weiter oben hat man dann
meistens sogenannte technische Direktoren
oder CTOs. CTO für
Chief Technology Officer
und die haben dann verschiedene
Bereiche unter sich. Spätestens
hier Leute, musst du das in
deine Twitter-Biografie schreiben.
Weil die ganzen
CTO-Dudes von irgendwelchen 2-3
Mann klitschen, schreiben das auch immer alle
fett. Und ins LinkedIn-Profil natürlich.
Wie technisch gruppiert
sind oder nach Finanzen gruppiert sind
oder was auch immer. Und ganz oben on top
dann, besonders in großen Konzernen, ist es meistens so,
dass man dann einen Technikvorstand hat. Der kontrolliert
also alles im Konzern, was irgendwie im
Bereich Technik ist oder eben halt auch noch
Risikovorstände oder was es da noch für Vorstände gibt.
Was brauche ich jetzt, um diese Rollen überhaupt
bekleiden zu können? Nun, ich muss natürlich zuallererst mal
ein gewisses Wissen um diese Rolle haben.
Das heißt, was sind meine Aufgaben?
Das ist eine Mega-Idee. Ich finde,
das ist auch super entspannt
im Background, oder?
Ich fahre einfach mit meinem Fahrrad ein bisschen
durch die Felder,
schnall mir eine GoPro vorne drauf,
mach irgendwie Hyper
Anti-Shake
Gedöns oder wie das heißt bei GoPro
an und dann habe ich
easy 15 Minuten Hintergrundmaterial.
Was ist meine Aufgabe
als Teamleiter, als Abteilungsleiter,
was auch immer.
Ich kann nicht labern, während ich
fahre.
Da kann ich nicht nichts
nachgucken, kann mir nichts
im Vorfeld aufschreiben. Ich muss
denken, fahren, reden
gleichzeitig. Das funktioniert nicht.
Management-Kompetenzen,
dass ich also weiß, worauf kommt das Management an?
Was sind die Aufgaben des Management?
Was ist die Zielsetzung davon? Und genau mit
diesen Management-Fähigkeiten einhergehen, sind natürlich
auch die Kompetenzen, Mitarbeiter
zu führen. In all diesen Ebenen
oder im Großteil dieser Ebenen, die ich eben erwähnt habe,
ist es von Relevanz, dass wir in der Lage sind,
Mitarbeiter führen zu können.
Also disziplinarisch zu walten,
Konflikte zu lösen, Mitarbeiter weiter
zu entwickeln, all diese Dinge, die damit verbunden sind.
Und ganz zum Schluss ist es natürlich von hoher
Relevanz, dass ich in der Lage bin, wirtschaftlich
zu denken. Der Scrum Master sollte den
Prozess so auslegen, dass er natürlich das Produkt
und das Team optimal unterstützt, aber gleichzeitig
auch wirtschaftlich ist. Der Architekt sollte
eine Softwareentwicklung oder eine Softwarearchitektur
Also man kann sich da echt vortrefflich
drüber schreiten, ob das ein Scrum Master machen
soll. Eigentlich sollte
ein Scrum Master, aus meiner Sicht,
kein Manager sein, sondern
einzig und allein sich darum kümmern,
dass, wie auch immer man da
Agilität auslegt, dass das
eingehalten wird.
Wobei hat er mit Prozess ja nicht ganz
unrecht. Ja, stimmt.
Hat er recht.
Ja.
Doch, dann
würde ich das schon ausreden.
Zumindest spätestens,
wenn die Leute auf die Idee kommen,
dass das Scrum Master auch gleichzeitig der
Projektleiter ist, dann kann er im Prinzip
den auch weglassen.
So auslegen, dass sie auch wirtschaftlich ist.
Und als Teamleiter, Abteilungsleiter
und so weiter ist dieses wirtschaftliche Denken
natürlich auch absolut erforderlich.
Können Softwareentwickler das jetzt am Ende des Tages gar nicht
und begleiten deswegen diese Rollen nicht?
Das ist natürlich nicht der Fall.
Doch, ich sehe das anders.
Ich glaube, die meisten Softwareentwickler sind keine
guten Führungskräfte oder wären es nicht.
Und das sieht man schon daran,
weil sie keinen Bock darauf haben.
Irgendwie musst du da
einen gewissen Zug
dazu auch haben und gewisse
gewisse
ja
einfach so ein bisschen
dass man das machen möchte.
Ja.
Muss ich da irgendwie so ein bisschen dazu berufen fühlen
nach dem Motto Ja, das ist was für mich.
Aber
ich glaube viele Softwareentwickler
beziehungsweise generell
viele ITler sind Kellerkinder wie ich.
Die haben keinen
Bock sich den ganzen Tag zu
90 Prozent mit anderen Menschen und
Meetings und Sachen auseinanderzusetzen.
Die wollen
Technikkrams machen.
Die wollen lieber sich mit Computer
mit ihrem Computer unterhalten
als mit anderen Leuten.
Die wollen wie ich im Keller sitzen
ihre Ruhe haben
und Technikkram basteln.
Das ist ja schon vielfältig genug.
Und es ist nicht so
sehr, dass die meisten richtig Bock haben mit ihren
Social Skills zu glänzen.
Ich muss sagen für Keller bin ich dieses Jahr
erstaunlich braun. Ich weiß auch nicht was da
geworden ist, wie das zustande
gekommen ist. Alle diese Dinge
auch wenn sie teilweise schwer zu lernen sind, kann man
in irgendeiner
Art und Weise lernen. Das heißt
kann man, kann man, sicherlich,
sicherlich. Man kann auch
programmieren lernen. Man kann
vieles lernen, aber man braucht einen gewissen
inneren
Hang dazu,
das machen zu wollen.
Und wenn ich schon überhaupt
keinen Bock auf andere Mitmenschen
habe, dann werde ich bestimmt nicht Führungskraft.
Tänzen kann ich mir aneignen,
Mitarbeiterführung kann man auch lernen, wirtschaftliches
Denken. Das mag sein,
das mag sein, dass
wir heute alle auch noch Hipster sind und mit Roller
rumfahren oder sowas. Kann alles
sein, aber wenn ich eins gemerkt
habe die letzten Jahre über und wie nennt man
das so?
Anekdotische
Erfahrung. Also wenn ich
eins die letzten Jahre über gelernt habe,
dass die Leute, die besonders
viel Plan haben,
das sind Leute,
mein Kellerkinder mag das falsche
Wort sein, das sind aber Leute,
die nicht einfach nur
Technik-Krams
machen,
weil es jetzt ihr Job ist,
sondern das sind Leute,
die nehmen
privat vielleicht sogar an irgendwelchen
Pen-Testing oder
Hacking-Wettbewerben
teil, haben
GitHub-Projekte,
sind vielleicht ab und zu mal
auf irgendeiner Konferenz,
haben Ahnung, was in ihrem
Lieblingstechnikumfeld
gerade so abgeht,
wissen Bescheid, wenn irgendwelche neuen
Programmiersprachen rauskommen, was da die Stärken
und Schwächen sind, haben sich das auch alles schon mal angeguckt,
interessieren sich generell
relativ vielfältig für alle möglichen Sachen,
guckt euch das mal an, was wir hier im Stream
schon alles gemacht haben. Wir haben von
Microcontroller-Entwicklung bis
Web-Interfaces,
Kubernetes-Cluster, wir haben alles
irgendwie schon mal irgendwo gestreift.
Und
das sind
halt einfach nicht die Leute,
die
den ganzen Tag
im Fitnessstudio hängen und ansonsten
auf irgendwelchen
coolen Hipster-Partys sind.
Es gibt sicherlich Ausnahmen,
aber
die meisten, die ich kenne, da ist das so.
Ich sag ja nicht, dass du
dein komplettes
Leben im Keller
verbringen musst
und
dich nicht traust, jemand anderem
in die Augen zu gucken oder so. Man muss es ja
nicht übertreiben.
Aber einen gewissen
Hang zum Kellerkind sein,
muss es da einfach geben.
Migdiet. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Dein ganzes Leben ist agile.
Ja, genau.
Genau, so ist es.
Und dementsprechend, da fließt halt auch
einfach viel Zeit rein, weil es dich eben
interessiert,
unabhängig von deinem Job.
Und ich
hab's heute gemerkt, Leute.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal mich als
Beispiel.
Ich hab das heute gemerkt.
Also heute war ein nicht
ganz so normaler Tag für mich.
Ich hab das heute gemerkt.
Also ich bin aufgestanden.
Ich muss
gerade überlegen.
Ich bin aufgestanden,
hab was gefuttert.
Dann bin ich eine Runde
Rennen gewesen.
Dann hab ich tatsächlich
kurz
vorm Rechner gehockt.
Dann bin ich Mittagessen gegangen.
Dann hab ich nochmal kurz eine halbe Stunde
vorm Rechner gehockt.
Und dann war ich
zwei Stunden
mit drum und dran
und vorbereiten so, zwei Stunden
Fahrrad fahren. Dann hab ich noch ein bisschen
draußen auf der Terrasse
gehockt mit der Katze.
Und ich war legit
nicht richtig vorm Rechner
bis
keine Ahnung
dann
war ich nicht am Rechner bis nach dem Abendessen.
Ich war erst um 18 Uhr
am Rechner so richtig.
Kann mir keiner erzählen, dass man
in dieser Zeit dann noch
die Energie
und Bock hat
jetzt noch
ich mach jetzt mein privates Softwareprojekt weiter
oder sowas. Ich hab jetzt Stream
angemacht heute Abend.
Das war kein so richtig normaler Tag für mich.
War halt recht umtriebig.
Aber irgendwie
ist halt auch die Zeit begrenzt, was du machen willst.
Sprich die Leute, die den ganzen Tag
Sport machen, im Fitnessstudio hängen,
auf irgendwelchen Hipsterpartys sind.
Wann sollen die
übelst krasses
deepes Technikknowledge
aufbauen? Das ist ja
schon eine reine Zeitfrage.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Deswegen sag ich, dass
viele
der richtig guten Technikleute
schon so ein bisschen den Hang
zum Kellerkind haben. So wie ich auch.
Ob ich technisch jetzt Ahnung hab, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber ich hab auf jeden Fall
den Hang zum Kellerkind.
Ja genau, das passt einfach nicht.
Du sitzt
oftmals eher
sieben Stunden an irgendeinem Problem
und denkst dir, alter, warum funktioniert der Scheiß nicht?
Und dann denkst du dir so, ah fuck, jetzt müsste ich mal langsam
auch was futtern gehen. Und wenn du das
gemacht hast,
dann ist der Tag gelaufen.
Dann hast du nicht so viel Zeit jetzt
zu sagen, ah ich geh jetzt nochmal kurz Fahrradfahren,
weil wahrscheinlich wird es dann demnächst schon dunkel.
19 Uhr ist Sonnenuntergang.
Ja, es ist, ich sag ja
nicht, dass man das so machen muss.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass ich
bei vielen Leuten, ich kann mich nicht
aussprechen, aber Dankeschön für den Sub,
dass ich bei vielen Leuten, die wirklich richtig krass
einen Blick haben, schon
sagen würde,
dass die ein bisschen
den Hang zum Kellerkind sein haben.
Und ich rede nicht so sehr von Leuten, die
es nur gut verkaufen können, dass sie richtig
krass Ahnung haben, sondern
Leute, von denen ich es persönlich schon gespürt
habe, dass sie Ahnung haben.
Gesehen habe,
dass sie Ahnung haben. Und das sind
oftmals ähnliche Typen, Leute.
So, jetzt gucken wir
das Video mal weiter.
Das Problem dahinter ist,
und das ist meine Theorie, eine ganz andere.
Denn wir als Softwareentwickler,
wir lieben Softwareentwicklung.
Wir lieben Frameworks, wir lieben Tools, wir lieben
Programmiersprachen. Wir lieben es einfach jeden Tag
unsere Kreativität dazu zu nutzen,
neue Software zu erstellen. Probleme
mit Hilfe von irgendwelchen IT-Dingen
zu lösen. Auf der anderen Seite
sind wir meistens nicht so.
Das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Nur nicht unbedingt Probleme,
also nicht unbedingt für die Firma
Probleme.
Ich glaube, jeder
ITler bastelt einfach gerne.
Das ist auch was,
was viele Leute, die wirklich
tiefgreifend technische Ahnung haben,
was ich da auch schon, eine Gemeinsamkeit, die ich da auch
schon gemerkt habe, ist, die Leute
basteln einfach gerne.
Dementsprechend interessieren die sich
natürlich auch für Neues,
aber die basteln gerne.
Und das kostet Zeit.
Du kannst nicht sagen,
ah, ich
baue mir
jetzt mal irgendwie einen
eigenen
Sensor, ich hole mir
jetzt einen ESP32 und
ich baue mir da jetzt einen eigenen Sensor
zum Fernsteuern für meine Klimaanlage,
baue mir eine eigene
Firmware für
und ich mache das halt abends
mal so 45 Minuten am Tag.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Bis du da richtig reingekommen bist,
kannst du schon ins Bett.
Das musst du dann,
musst du dich da einfach mal 1-2 Wochen
mit beschäftigen.
Kannst du natürlich auch, musst du es ja
nicht jeden Tag machen, aber du wirst
immer mal wieder
3-4-5 Stunden Sessions haben,
wo du dich wirklich
intensiv damit beschäftigst
und so langsam aber sicher dahinter kommst,
wie funktioniert denn der Kram.
Das kannst du nicht einfach mal sagen, ah ja, gut, wenn ich
mit allem anderen fertig bin, dann 45 Minuten
mal, das funktioniert nicht. Klar, man kriegt
auf der Arbeit, wenn man in einem gewissen Bereich
arbeitet, sicherlich auch schon das
ein oder andere mit,
aber ganz ehrlich,
das meiste Technik-Know-How
habe ich nicht dadurch erlangt,
dass ich für die Arbeit irgendwas gemacht
habe, sondern es war eher umgedreht.
Ich habe mich mit irgendwas beschäftigt und ihr habt es hier im
Stream gesehen, wir haben alles schon mal irgendwie
ansatzweise gestreift, wir haben sogar mal
Kobol im Stream gemacht,
zur Belustigung des Chats
und es ist eher umgedreht,
dass sich dadurch schon ein paar
Sachen mich auf die Idee gebracht haben,
hey, könnte man das
nicht auf der Arbeit auch brauchen? Und hat man
ja auch oftmals dann gebraucht.
Ja gut, bei mir ist es natürlich noch besser,
ich arbeite nur 4 Tage die Woche, ich habe ja
prinzipiell einen Tag mehr Zeit.
Und das Ding ist halt einfach,
wenn du auf der Arbeit sitzt und wirst
dafür bezahlt zu programmieren an irgendwas,
was dich persönlich eigentlich nicht interessiert,
dann machst du das halt,
findest da vielleicht auch
ein paar ein oder andere interessante Sachen
drin, das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt
für die Firma relevant und wichtig sein,
aber übrigens auch
ein Punkt, wo ich sagen würde,
bei allen Leuten, die,
oder bei den meisten Leuten, das ist so eine Gemeinsamkeit,
bei Leuten, von denen ich sagen würde, die haben richtig Ahnung,
ist, dass sie eine
gewisse
ordentlich,
wie was ordentlich ist,
Vorstellung haben. Und mit ordentlich meine ich
nicht, dass die Leute ordentlich sind.
Das schon mal gar nicht.
Die haben aber eine gewisse
Vorstellung davon, wie man
technische
ja
Projekte, wie man
technische Sachen
umsetzt, so dass
sie sich gut anfühlen.
Das ist egal, ob das jetzt aus
Infrastruktursicht ist,
aus Deploymentsicht,
aus Anwendungsentwicklersicht.
Eigentlich egal,
aber alle diese Leute haben eine
gewisse Vorstellung. Die können sich da
auch manchmal ein bisschen
abweichen von, es gibt dann wilde Diskussionen
und sowas, aber
oftmals sind die gar nicht
so sehr voneinander weg.
Die haben eine gewisse Vorstellung, wie muss
was ordentlich sein.
Zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal was.
Also, wir haben es jetzt lange Zeit
so gemacht für ein Projekt.
Wir haben unsere Cloud-Infrastruktur
immer
schnell, schnell hingebaut,
weil irgendeiner mal irgendwo
was testen wollte. Das heißt, wir hatten
für jede
Umgebung, also es gibt
ein Entwicklungsprojekt,
es gibt
ein Entwicklungsprojekt, es gibt ein
Integrationsprojekt, es gibt ein
Produktionsprojekt und wir
haben da ein paar Terraform-Files angelegt,
so einfach immer random hingeschmissen
für jedes Projekt.
Kein gemeinsames Modul,
wo alle drauf zugreifen.
Einfach ein paar Zeilen reingeklatscht,
gestartet,
irgendwas wurde in der Cloud aufgebaut
und dann hast du dann zum jeweiligen Entwickler oder
zum Tester gesagt,
guck mal, da steht jetzt ein Cluster,
guck mal, wie du damit klarkommst.
Und
das ist nix, was
sich ordentlich anfühlt.
Was wir jetzt gemacht haben ist,
wir haben jetzt ein eigenes Modul gebaut,
was uns unsere Datenbank so hinstellt,
wie sie sein soll in der Cloud,
den Cluster so hinstellt, wie er sein soll
und auch schon ein paar Parameter in dem Cluster
per Kubernetes-YAML
einspielt, bevor man überhaupt
sich einmalig dagegen authentifiziert,
dass alles da ist.
Und das Modul wird jetzt als Base genommen
für alle Umgebungen, nicht mal so einzelne
immer sich voneinander
wegentwickelnde
Infrastructure-as-Code-Stände
und das ist was, wo ich denke,
okay, das fühlt sich für mich
irgendwie ordentlich oder
nach einer sinnvollen Umsetzung
an und das ist auch was,
wovon Leute, die
ich dafür halte, dass sie viel Plan haben,
die haben ein gewisses
Gespür dafür,
wie man was
ordentlich ist vielleicht nicht so sehr das richtige
Wort, wie man was,
mir fällt aber auch nix besseres ein,
wie man was
tja
ordentlich umsetzt, mir fällt kein besseres Wort
für ein.
Gescheit, wie man was gescheit umsetzt,
ja, genau,
sinnvoll, rund, ja,
rund trifft's eigentlich ganz gut, genau.
Aber jetzt gucken wir mal weiter.
Genau, das haben auch
viele von den Leuten, die sich überlegen, okay,
wie können wir das jetzt,
die einfach auch schon mal ein bisschen
vorausdenken können
oder ein bisschen um die Ecke denken können und sagen, hey,
das ist zwar nice,
Beispiel, ein ganz, ganz
simples Beispiel, brauchst gar kein
super krasses Technik-Know-how führen,
ja, zum Beispiel
haben wir eine Domain,
nennen wir es jetzt mal
blablablub
.projekt
.googlecloud
.blablabla
.de
so
und dementsprechend hast du dann
eine
Subdomain davon,
beispielsweise für irgendein Webfrontend,
ist dann frontend
.blabla
.projekt
.google
.blub.de
So, das ist halt für den Arsch,
weil niemand von
dem, der sich am Ende
fachlich für das Frontend
sich da einloggen muss und da Dinger macht,
sich das jemals
merken kann. Natürlich, die können sich das alles
bookmarken, aber intuitiv ist es
nicht. Deswegen kam
jemand auf die glorreiche Idee und das fand ich
gut, das hat sich gleich mit meinem
wie ich es als
ordentlich und rund und sinnvoll empfinde
gedeckt, kam der um die
Ecke und hat gemeint, sag mal Max, was hältst
du davon, wenn wir die Domain
einfach mal wegschmeißen und
irgendwas kürzeres nehmen?
Ja, das finde ich ist eine gute Idee
und jetzt haben wir quasi
produktname
.
.blablub.de
für das Produktivsystem
und da unten drunter haben wir dann sowas
wie dev.
.
.projekt.blablub.de
ist eigentlich viel naheliegender, ja
weil wen juckt es, dass es bei Google läuft?
Wen juckt es, was sonst noch
irgendwie dabei ist? Das muss einfach
muss einfach griffig sein, dass man
sich das merken kann, dass man da auch drauf
kommt, wenn man nicht gerade einen Bookmark dahin
hat.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal das Video weiter.
.
Das ist wohl richtig.
BWL ist natürlich
liebt ja jeder Techniker bekannter
Maßen.
.